- I like McDonalds, but their breakfast
has just never appealed to me.
- I've never had an
American McDonalds before.
- When I was growing up
I was a Burger King kid,
and then when I got older I
started loving Chick-fil-A,
and then Chick-fil-A
started hating gay people,
and now I don't eat fast food.
- I think eating McDonalds
once every 16 years
isn't going to be terrible.
- I don't know if franchise are involved.
- How could it not be delicious?
That's lazy as (beep) man.
- It looks like someone trampled on it.
- Wait I've never had a
burrito for breakfast,
I didn't realized that was a thing.
- What's in this?
Nope.
- I think that's good.
- Okay, I did not want to swallow that.
- It taste like actual eggs.
- This is why I have
avoided it all this time
because I knew it would be delicious.
- It's like a little too slimy.
- And look, I feel like that's even like a
hint of a vegetable.
- It doesn't look like
meat, it's kind of gray.
But I'll eat it anyway
because it taste good.
- Ooh, a sausage McGriddle.
It's the McDonalds coming out.
- It looks so gross and like sad.
- Oh, it has an M on it.
- That's fancy.
- What's in it?
- They've like injected
syrup into the pancake.
- Is it raisins?
- That's really weird.
- It like (beep) smashes you
over the head with syrup.
- Genius.
- I don't think I would ever order this,
but I would eat it.
- All right, so I've heard of a McMuffin,
this is like something
people are like way into.
- I always thought it was like a word
for something sexual.
- This one has the
nutritional facts on it.
I'm just going to skip that.
- It's pretty delicious.
The cheese is like yellow blue sauce.
- It has that like plastic
look to it, you know?
- It's just too much bread,
I'm just eating bread.
Take that off, let's see if that's better.
But now I have to look at what I'm eating,
which is kind of a nightmare.
- This one is not that bad.
- It taste like a dementor
kissed the flavor out of this.
- But it's not that good either.
- Where's that burrito?
I want that burrito back.
Oh man, this looks like
an airplane breakfast.
- This syrup is so intoxicating.
- I've never like eaten syrup before, so.
- [Voiceover] She's
never had syrup before.
- I'm just going to put it all on
because I think that's what
American people would do.
- I mean there's been syrup around me,
I just haven't eaten it.
- It's not an insult,
but I know that you all love syrup.
- I'm going to say the
pancakes are not bad.
- It definitely taste like a pancake.
- Because the bread looked good.
I mean I would put Vegemite on this.
- Hashbrown, I'd give it
a 10 out of 10 on grease.
- It looks like a big chicken McNugget.
- That's the best thing we've had so far.
- I don't think I've
had a hashbrown before,
but it's good.
I like it.
- I don't really like tater tot,
so I'm just going to say it,
go ahead and hate me.
- I don't think I would want to eat
McDonalds breakfast again.
- If there was nothing else around,
yeah I'd have it.
- Am I going to eat it again?
Yeah, probably.
- Give me 16 years.